what's going on reject nation greg and
john here we're gonna watch today from
watchy mojo top 10 biggest changes in
zack snyder's justice league from whedon
to the original
so a couple of things gotta mention
reaction highlights for youtube are
being worked on
and we're gonna start rolling them out
into several parts next week so watch
everyone else's horror up and then watch
ours next week the full length
is up on patreon if you want to sync up
watch long list that's our patreon right
now secondly we're doing a spoiler talk
today prepare you some questions and
whatever if you want to chime in and
hang out with us
all things snyder cut uh we figured you
know
we're likely to miss a question that
people will be like why didn't you talk
about this so for live
the only you before we go to
spoiler talk this might be a good video
to kick us off right into it let's do it
he said you've come no that's i hope
you're not too late always welcome to
watch mojo and today we're counting down
our picks for the top 10 biggest changes
in
zack snyder's justice league the time
has come
take up your mother no that's the wheat
that's the weeding you want to kill me
i'm your best friend of life
but turned into this for this list we're
looking at the most
significant tweets oh do you remember
that
how far have we come
[Laughter]
well i remember they're just storyboards
oh
oh the beauty i'm pausing way too early
but damn how far have we come
the joy is radiating [ __ ] tweaks
zack snyder made to his long-awaited
director's cut of justice league
do you think these changes improved the
film yes
and as you might imagine a spoiler alert
is now in effect
number 10 the final battle i'm going to
take out that tower and knock down that
shield though
you get to step in watching the
theatrical cut of justice
league the climax caught us off guard
with its reddish orange skies and huge
imagery it's
so weird looking at this new backgrounds
in the early trailers
which we honestly found more atmospheric
sorry
we stored the blue hues for the final
battle although that's not the only
change
joss whedon added that yeah russian
family in his version
everyone loves that russian family what
it's like for the people on the ground
who picks this place to put down roots
people that have been kicked out of
everywhere else
while we get where whedon was coming
from this subplot didn't contribute much
and the family wasn't sorely missed in
the snyder cut steppenwolf received a
more violent end as well
burning that [ __ ] was so cool
martian manhunter okay yeah going back
to the um
final battle it's it's bizarre because
like both my fiance and i we really
enjoyed
the joss whedon one for the saturday
morning cartoon it was we're defenders
of it but i've always championed this
cut i gotta make that clear i've always
championed always thought it'd be better
so
as much as i enjoyed and it just
it's so weird to watch this movie
and go oh i don't like that undercut
anymore
that saturday morning charm is all good
it's all gone
just like oh it just ruined all he did
was ruin it now it's just a reminder of
how much worse everything got to get to
that point and now looking at even just
these final moments of the big battle
i'm like i don't even recall the big
superhero the crazy cool superhero shot
you know great like that's the moment i
want to talk about the spoiler talk
is with the shot the the the the
superhero po has been the battle when
batman's driving his car
and it shows how great my brain is right
now it's going to be a great spoiler
batman
batman's in his like car and cyborg's
flying
you know the hero shot i'm talking about
like when you get to that show you're
like
the justice league they're teaming up ah
and that's not even like that's the
early part of the battle you know
like we're getting to business number
nine martian manhunter
jean jones better known as martian
manhunter is one of several heroes we
had hoped to see in the theatrical cut
allies from other worlds while we got no
such appearance in that version
snyder initially had plans for the
character on a commentary track for the
ultimate cut of batman vs superman
snyder mentioned that martian manhunter
was lieutenant general calvin swanwick
incognito
what's your source on this a tin foil
hat in a storyboard that didn't make
whedon's version
martian manhunter was going to visit
lois lane's apartment under the guise of
martha kent
while actor harry lennox previously
appeared in man of steel and batman vs
superman
the snyder cut officially solidified
swanwick and martian manhunter as one in
the same
oh yeah the world needs you too lois
i miss those daily planet artists by
junkie xl
[Music]
that's the hero shot i'm talking about
yeah there it is
but talking about martian manhunter real
quick rewatching on the second time
it's one of those cases where it does
feel like
if we get the other justice leagues
it'll feel more
necessary to have martian manhunter in
here yeah
that's one part of it that i was like
okay yeah you work for the setup but in
terms of like completing this one tail
it's like a good teaser of what's more
to come with you martian manhunter
and of course getting like there's
things about it that i love and there's
other parts about it where i'm nitpicky
yeah yeah of where and i'm admittedly
nitpicky because i'm not really
like i could do that yeah by the time
you get like that tease that nts you're
like okay this feels like a little bit
like it doesn't need to be here for this
one but if we do get justice league two
and three or even just two yeah then i'm
like all right okay
that's perfect yeah yeah that's like one
thing i think we've all learned from
looking at how at least zack snyder's
films have gone is that a lot of things
i mean not everyone gets the benefit of
three films to build on some of these
but that's part of
the charm i think is that he does
establish certain things that maybe in
the
at first feel like they're not entirely
necessary or whatever but then grow in
significance and then later you're like
damn i'm glad that they actually
stuck to that so yeah that's currently
whereas i've heard that complaint about
martian manhunter and that's
but i mean come on the visual effects on
them look so cool
they look great they look great and just
to make it clear my only nitpicky part
comes in from like the very end i
actually really
like the fact that we have the
confirmation that general swanwick
was in fact martian manhunter this whole
time and i really liked the scene
between he was disguised as martha kent
while talking with lois lane so yeah you
know
overall i'm very enthused at martian man
or gotta appear in here and it was
interesting too
going back and watching um man of steel
and bbs and watching harry lennox in
there not so much in the
man of steel but bvs i'm like i can see
how he's martian man
at bvs i was able to see it number eight
new music by junkie xl
whatever your thoughts on snyder's
filmmaking style are his movies almost
always have amazing soundtracks
junkie xl aka tom hulkenborg
collaborated with fellow composer han
zimmer on man of steel and batman vs
superman
zac is so good at build up to work
to the finale moments of his [ __ ] that's
so good
and like the use of the music oh yeah
and that great blurred shot for
something elseman usually goes hand in
hand with dc projects
and while his justice league score
wasn't bad it was a far cry from his
batman days
junkie xl was brought back on board for
the snyder cut and his music
did not disappoint particularly the crew
at war power track
oh it's a great soundtrack yeah man
i will say though like i i undoubtedly
prefer
it's an infinitely superior more uh
powerful soundtrack as opposed to the
whedon version
i think for whedon's version the the
elfman score works though
yeah to be as like fair as possible yeah
yeah of course to that tone and what
they were going for with that it's a lot
more appropriate
you know what else i want to point out
so this shot for some reason in whedon's
cut is blurred
all right and it doesn't need to be
gordon's got glasses on
it doesn't need to be blurred i realize
this shot is infinitely more powerful
even if it was blurred in zack snyder's
version
it's not but if it was it's infinitely
more powerful in the moment because
in zack snyder's justice league this is
the first time you're seeing him in the
bat suit
like an hour and a half into the movie
yeah where in the other one he's like
you know he gets the guy from mine
hunters and he's like i need fear of
sweating or something
you know at the very top of the movie
like gotham look cool in that
in that sequence but this is a really
rewarding
shot and it warrants this level of rudon
of batman
yeah because of when it occurs in zack
snyder's justice league
steppenwolf's updated design oh yeah we
know all about this one
my lord for many
one of the theatrical version's biggest
letdowns was its villain
aside from being far less interesting
than his comic book counterpart
steppenwolf had a generic look obviously
rendered through cgi
while snyder steppenwolf is still
clearly draped in cg
his design is a vast upgrade not only is
his armor infinitely less silly
but steppenwolf's facial features are
far more atrocious
in a good way
while a cooler look is one thing the
snyder cut also delves deeper into
steppenwolf's backstory and motivation
as well as his dynamic with darkseid
that said
steppenwolf isn't the only major
antagonist this time around
it shall be so my master
number six more aquaman
i mean the number six could be all more
of everyone yeah
cyborg what i
really notice about steppenwolf in this
version especially beyond just the
writing the design with his
eyes specifically oh yeah breathe a lot
more humanity when he's in steppenwolf
armor he's really terrifying and like
while he's like gross to look at
um he just has his regular self there's
this pain
and loss in his eyes yeah you know a lot
of expression just like
real solemn guy uh underneath it all
he's like sad yeah put it bluntly and i
love that with his portrayal like you
get that just in his eyes alone
before james juan made aquaman one of
the dceu's mvps
justice league didn't give jason mamoa a
ton to work with
aside from that one infamous line a man
it's hard to even remember what arthur
curry did in that version he stand on
the lasso with this
yeah it was funny originally snyder
planned to set the stage for juan's film
aside from giving mara a more prominent
role willem dafoe shot a scene as
neuters volkow
the time has come
take up your mother's trident there was
also to be
more exploration of atlantis mythos and
development for arthur himself
number five building a better
oh and he smiles that little smile right
there
out of the central six heroes cyborg is
arguably the one who got the shortest
end of the stick in the original version
if these i don't know i'm not the one
paying for them
the film did little to flesh out victor
stone's life before his accident
his relationship with his father or his
personality
virtually everything about the character
is improved upon in the snyder cut
although the cg can still be hit and
miss nevertheless
stone finally emerges as somebody we
root for and empathize with
as opposed to just another member of the
team snyder described cyborg as
quote the heart of the movie which
shines through in the final product
we're still waiting to hear more about
that standalone cyborg movie
but his development here has us more
optimistic
he used that power to keep me alive
but turned into this number four
superman
i just realized maybe hbo max can give
him and zack snyder a solo cyborg movie
oh they could
there are some moments that really got
me mad that they're not in the moments
that i'm like this could have fit
yeah that's kind of like the upsetting
like what were you thinking
sometimes there are moments where you're
like okay i get you're going for a
certain run time but you still could
have fit
this in yeah um especially the scene
with his uh all the football stuff and
his mom are the things that really got
to me oh of course
we don't need to care about our heroes
and then same thing with aquaman too
absolutely he undoubtedly gets way more
did he is
awesome and way more presence just like
way more
gravity on screen like you could really
feel everyone's
character they built underneath the
dialogue too in this cut
yeah you know man like the aquaman stuff
is like i
love jason momoa's performance yeah i
love all their performances but jason
momoa was the one where i wasn't
expecting
to love his work that much more yeah
right
and it's not even like he has like a
crate like there are some more lanterns
but i mean he's got just some
different tone to the way they capture
him in the
in zack's version yeah and then volkow
take up your mother's trident
i'm gonna change my hair after you do
it's set up for that elf cut more mine's
mirror you know in the first scene i was
cool with it and then when she came back
later i was like oh what happened to
your accent
like i was just talking the subtitle
superman in black all the hopes and
dreams
we get that whedon was going for a more
lighthearted tone with his justice
league
but why lose soup's black suit it's one
of the most memorable aspects of the
death of superman's story arc
with superman's inevitable return we all
assumed he'd dress in black for the
occasion
i believe in truth but i'm also a big
fan of justice
instead
big
yeah this version also restored the
deleted scene where supes meets alfred
i'm assuming you're alfred
overall the superman here is
significantly different than in whedon's
interpretation
particularly around the upper lip yes
ma'am
number three iris west um
yeah there's a lot of pausing here the
superman's line when he finally shows up
at the coolest most badass moment the
axe
just lands on him just goes not
impressed yeah i
was so bad such a good
obvious whatever this line is like i
actually
really liked henry cavill in uh in uh
the jaw sweet income i did i thought he
was a i thought he was really fun
and to be fair it was actually easier
for them
to have kept the red suit red blue suit
because that's what they shot it in
yeah yeah and then zach changed it like
his plan was to always change it zach is
just really good cgi that it looks like
he's wearing an actual black suit and
you never think it's a color corrector
yeah
it's weird because as much as like
superman was arguably my favorite part
of just
of the joss whedon part i do prefer this
take yeah weird anything i prefer
anything i liked a lot about i prefer
here and then a lot became really bad in
my eyes oh yeah because i mean like it's
it's fun and there is a sort of classic
superman-ness that justice league
eventually captures but this just
actually the race with him and flash at
the end yeah
yeah i think that's a lot of like yeah
there's some fun stuff there but i feel
like what we lose in
fun we make up for in zack's version
with just
actual heart and actual just like
character catharsis you know
yeah and it feels like the clark kent
that is
actually established yeah it feels
it feels like the completion of his arc
in a way over yeah these three movies
and
and ironically as he meets more super
folks he
you know fully comes into himself yeah i
guess that's one scene that zack
snyder's justice league would have liked
a scene of superman just interacting
with the team
yeah that's true that's like a kind of
one beat that'll be like i would have
been cool to just see them like actually
all talking with him especially when
flash
does have that line of he was my hero
yeah you know yeah i would have
liked to have one scene where they're
all like like a scene
yeah they should've got joss whedon
hey i know i know there's been some bad
blood but we want a post credit scene
where everyone's getting food you doubt
iris west and the flash i'm so sorry i'm
late this list is basically more of this
person more of this
one is another one
you know there's more to the flash than
quips
dostoevsky dan merle's favorite
makes more of an effort to explore the
death of barry's mother the
incarceration of his father
and his romance with iris west actress
kirstie clemons was
going to make her dc eu debut as iris in
justice league
but her contributions were left on the
cutting room floor did anyone else think
that he was going to
jokingly put a hot dog in her mouth i
did i
guess this is going to go full on is
this gonna try to one up johnson league
in terms of goofy humor
toughness i don't think this will go
over well put it in his pocket it was
funnier
iris finally appeared in this version
most prominently during a scene where
barry saves her from a potentially fatal
car
accident fatal all right yeah
snyder also aimed to make more sense of
the future flash from batman versus
superman
which ties into our next entry number
two jared leto as the joker
a truce bruce
after the mostly negative reception to
suicide squad
joaquin phoenix's oscar-winning
portrayal of joker and not even getting
a cameo in birds of prey
jared leto's future in the dc eu seemed
to be up in the air
so you can imagine our surprise when
leto popped up at the end of the snyder
cuts trailer
complete with longer hair and messier
lips
we live in a society
isn't that right
[Music]
batman they don't say that they don't i
love how they cut it here
where society has become much much
stranger
you want to kill me i'm your best friend
although snyder didn't originally intend
to incorporate the joker
lettel was enlisted after the director's
cut got the go-ahead
joker plays an important role in this
version having stolen the mother box
that allows the flash to travel back in
time
really is that the context of this
oh we should have watched some ending
explain video
his next reaction did not know that
if you're on your phone make sure you go
into your settings that's why zach threw
us off with like the police badges and
all this others
number one darkseid
that is the biggest change he's actually
in this
and he's an integral part wouldn't it be
the central villain in the theatrical
cut
at the very least though we thought the
film would set him up for future
installments
aside from a brief mention darkseid was
a no-show
for the unity
for dark side the trailers for the
snyder cut quickly established the dark
side would play a meteor role in this
version
portrayed by ray porter darkseid made
his long-awaited live-action film debut
here
i will stride across their bones and
bask in the glow of anti-life
and all of existence shall
be this version also made room for some
of darkseid's followers
including dasad and granny goodness
while we're sure the dc eu has even
bigger plans for darkseid
and apocalypse this was a satisfying
taste
for now do you agree with our picks
great job watch mojo
that was a fun ass video and yeah i
would agree dark side is the biggest one
considering he is a character who
is woven in throughout is mentioned
throughout and is
completely eliminated yes at all costs
in the other world version because yeah
a lot of it is like
redone or expanding upon and like yeah
we don't get any iris west
that is one scene though and um
that's a whole context with dark side
but yeah but dark side yeah it just made
it
completely redefined steppenwolf it is
such a major part of it and what's great
is like
darkseid it easily could have just been
a character who
is only there to uh set up for a sequel
but he
feels necessary to be in this one as
well he feels like a driving like force
for a lot of this action
he seems like a he's a character who
does set up the sequels
but he's very integral to being in this
in this installment um especially for
the scenes with steppenwolf that he has
and
uh it's great because anytime he is on
screen yeah he commands
like the i know it's two different
people like there's ray porter doing the
voice
and then there's um whoever does the
mocap either way
like whenever he's on screen it's
magnifico yeah
yeah he's got so much presence it's like
steppenwolf gets better
by being a character at all in this cut
and also therefore
even more even more so by having an
actual like organization a whole world
like there's a whole world that comes
with dark side that yeah
like to take that out of the joss whedon
cut and then to water down steppenwolf
so much i just i just can't imagine what
they were thinking
because at least if they had done
steppenwolf but kept darkseid that would
have at least been a bit more
interesting
yeah or had more motivation behind it
than seeming just like yeah just throw a
villain in there because we're doing
supers
all right guys well right now it's 12 45
i'm moving we should be doing a live
stream in a couple hours
and uh hopefully i'm able to make it in
time to get this video up subscribe
click the notification bell hit that
like button and catch you guys soon